(Casting)
Evo is the pinnacle of fighting game competition. And this year's installment  gave us its fair share of highlights.
Now it wasn’t all meditation and peak performance, though.
There were moments, like the G cosplay, that made us cringe just a little bit.
(Casting)
Then there were times when a play did not quite go according to plan.
And of course there were the moments that broke the tension and made us all laugh.
(Casting)
Now we’ve got a whole video for you guys on the highlights, combos and pop offs at this year's competition.
But today, we’re celebrating the best fails and the funny moments from Evo 2018.
(Casting)
Look guys we've all been there.
You've finally opened up your opponent, and you know in your mind exactly how brutal your next combo will be.
This is your shot at glory, and then you drop it and he wins the round.
Look it happens to the best of us. Literally.
(Casting)
You know guys one of the things we love about the FGC is that they don’t take themselves too seriously all the time.
I mean sometimes you just have to forget about the roar of the crowd at Mandalay Bay.
You have to leave aside the sick combos, the upsets, the new tech and just have a laugh.
Here are some of the funniest moments from EVO on the mic.
(Casting)
Well guys there it is. Those are some of our favorite moments that made us laugh, and a few that made us cringe from EVO this year.
Now if you’ll excuse me, I need to go work on my G cosplay.
Uhh does anyone know where I can get gold face paint?